I do love Chicago and I actually lived
here for the summer back when I was in
my 20s and I have to say you coming back
now it feels like I I never left so you
know your way around I think I know this
town like the back of my hand
that's how well I know Chicago well yeah
but you only lived here for one summer
and that was a while ago it doesn't
matter I will say this I'm going on a
limb I think nobody knows more about
Chicago than I do I really believe that
nobody well then you should have no
trouble passing the just invented
Chicago citizenship test administered by
none other than the mayor of Chicago
himself Rahm Emmanuel
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you ready for your citizenship test
yes I am ready for the Chicago
citizenship test I just want you to know
the whole idea of citizenship and
residency is kind of a touchy subject
for me so we worked hard on this okay
all right I think I can handle it all
right here it goes all right here we go
what is Chicago's nickname the Windy
City
what was the Willis Tower formerly
called the Sears Tower very good
how many people are there in Chicago 2.7
million how many bars are there in
Chicago how many what how many bars are
there 4.7 million
what does the 2000 in Blues Brothers
2000 stand for the number of people who
saw it and why did Al Capone come from
New York City to Chicago to study improv
hey what is the windiest place in
Chicago the men's room at Giordano's
what's the dirtiest sounding street in
Chicago wacker
what is the greatest threat facing this
country today the Green Bay Packers
please repeat the following words but
with a heavy Chicago accent these DS
those dose them damn they're there the
mayor the mayor very good repeat after
me
there are 3,000 thoughtful thespians who
thoroughly thrived in Chicago's theater
scene I think there are 3,000 thoughtful
that's been to thoroughly thrived in
Chicago 13 I think
okay are you ready to go on oh yeah okay
I'll tell you what color we've dyed the
Chicago River and you have to tell me
what we're celebrating
okay green st. Patty's Day Red Bulls
championship Paisley because Oprah set
so yellow what's that one yellow yellow
that's also from celebrating st. Patty's
Day
a little delayed but they got it right
that's okay this Chicago's second city
alum had a recurring role on the Disney
series Wizards of Waverly Place as uncle
cowboy not mr. mayor I'd like to use a
lifeline if I could is that allowed
okay we're in all right please welcome
Chicago native and star of Curb Your
Enthusiasm Jeff Garlin
Jeff this is very important who played
uncle Kelbo on Wizards of Waverly Place
me and finally did you come here looking
for trouble
no I just came here to do the Super Bowl
shuffle
we have a second left before you go it's
only fair I answered several questions
about Chicago now I think it's your turn
mr. Mayer would you like to see him
answer alright here we go
alright I'm gonna name a famous Chicago
athlete you have to tell me what their
nickname would be if they were a mobster
Hey
first one Michael Jordan Mikey's six
rings Shoeless Joe Jackson Joey no shoes
Dick Butkus
Richard heinie smoocher William the
refrigerator Perry William the
refrigerator Perry
[Applause]